this is jocko podcast number 262
with echo charles and me jocko willink
good evening echo good evening
the president of the united states takes
pleasure in presenting the medal of
honor
to colonel merritt a edson
united states marine corps for service
as set forth in the following citation
for extraordinary heroism and
conspicuous
intrepidity above and beyond the call of
duty
as commanding officer of the first
marine raider battalion
with parachute battalion attached during
action against
enemy japanese forces in the solomon
islands on the night of 1314 september
1942. after the airfield on guadalcanal
had been seized from the enemy on august
8th
colonel edson with a force of 800 men
was assigned to the occupation and
defense of a ridge dominating the jungle
on either side of the airport
facing a formidable japanese attack
which
augmented by infiltration had crashed
through
our front lines he by skillful handling
of his troops
successfully withdrew his forward units
to a reserve line
with minimum casualties when the enemy
in a subsequent series of violent
assaults
engaged our force in desperate
hand-to-hand combat
with bayonets rifles pistols grenades
and knives
colonel edson although continuously
exposed a hostile fire throughout the
night
personally directed defense of the
reserve position
against a fanatical foe of greatly
superior numbers
by his astute leadership and gallant
devotion to duty
he enabled his men despite severe losses
to cling tenaciously to their position
on the vital ridge thereby retaining
command
not only of the guadalcanal airfield but
also
of the first division's entire offensive
installations in the surrounding area
signed franklin d roosevelt
and that is an example of the
level of heroism that was required
to achieve victory in the battle of
guadalcanal
which lasted from august 7th 1942 until
february 9th 1943
six months and two days
of just absolutely brutal
and savage fighting and we've
covered some of that in several books on
the podcast
and we even had dean ladd on the podcast
who received a battlefield commission on
guadalcanal and went on to fight
at tarawa and saipan and tinian
but i recently received a copy
of a book from a podcast listener by the
name of david
i guess i'm a little cautious about
giving out full names because i don't
know
you know don't know the background so
a guy named david he sent me a buckle
it's actually not a book technically
it's a fleet marine force reference
publication
fm fmfrp 12
tac 110 the title is
fighting on guadalcanal so thank you
david for sending that to me
and and the book is filled with all
kinds of layers
one of them being the the medal of honor
citation that i started with there's
there's an additional layer in this
which is that this that this fleet
marine force
reference publication was put together
by a guy named colonel red reader
who was west point class of 1926
who led the 12th infantry regiment
who win the d-day and he eventually was
wounded and he received the
the distinguished service crossing the
silver star and the legion of merit and
a bronze star and a purple heart
and he retired in 1946 and then he
worked as the athletic director
back at west point and eventually became
an author
and he wrote a bunch of books including
a memoir which is called
born at revelly so
i'm sure at some point we will cover
that book on this podcast
but for tonight i wanted to
i wanted to go to this book which which
is what i'm guessing is sort of the
beginning of colonel reader's
writing career was to put together this
this manual
fighting on guadalcanal
and it's the direct lessons learned and
let's get right into it
so here's the forward
to secure the point of view of the
fighting men in the salman islands
lieutenant colonel russell p reader jr
that's
who i just mentioned of the operations
division
of the war department general staff was
designated as my personal representative
he reported to major general vandegrift
united states marine corps
and major general patch u.s army on
guadalcanal and discussed with many
officers and soldiers
their experiences in jungle fighting
against the japanese
the stories of these men as told the
colonel reader have been printed
for your information the american
marines and doughboys
show us that the [__] is no superman
he is a tricky vicious and fanatical
fighter
but they are beating him day after day
theirs is a priceless record of the
gallantry
and resourcefulness of the american
fighting man at his best
soldiers and officers alike should read
these notes and seek to apply their
lessons
we must cash in on the experience which
these and other brave men
have paid for in blood
so that's what this book is there's an
opening note from
major general vandegriff
just a very famous commanding general
the first
marine uh division he says
i desire to thank general marshall for
the message which he has just sent me
i passed this message of congratulations
on to my men
my message to the troops of general
marshalls in training for this type of
warfare
is to go back to the tactics of the
french and
indian days this is not meant
facitiously study their tactics
and fit in our modern weapons and you
have a solution
i refer to the tactics and leadership of
the days
of rogers rangers so there you go
already we're talking about we got to
make some things a little bit different
we gotta we gotta look at the way we
used to fight
and if you think about that attitude of
fighting with the rangers
with rogers rangers with the french
indian war you know this is the big
difference between
you know the way the british wanted to
fight which was we're all lined up
we're standing in ranks and we're going
to shoot and then you shoot and then we
shoot back at you
we're not doing that you know that's
that's how we won the revolutionary war
because we're going to fight a different
way
the early form of maneuver warfare so
that's what this book is this is a bunch
of just
short anecdotal quotes
from a bunch of marines mainly
about what their experiences are on
guadalcanal
a bunch of great information gunnery
sergeant
h l beardsley
company g fifth marines i've been in the
marine six
i've been in the marine 16 years and
i've been in three expeditions to china
and five engagements since i've been in
the solomons
i will say that this 1942 model recruit
we are getting can drink
more water than six old timers
we have to stress water discipline all
the time
they don't seem to realize what real
water discipline is we have too many
ncos and the marines who are
nambi pamby and beat around the bush our
ncos are gradually toughing
toughening up and are seeing reasons why
they must meet their responsibilities
respectfully speaking sir i think that
when
officers make an nco they should go over
in their minds
what kind of nco will he make in the
field
water discipline there's something you
don't hear very often you got to go deep
into the field before you start
talking about water discipline because
guess what and i don't know when did the
word
hydrate do you remember pre the word
hydrate yes
right yeah hydrate was a new thing yeah
it's a relatively new thing
yeah as far as the expression hydrate
rather i think even the idea
because when i was a kid we didn't under
we didn't have the word
hydrate because hydrate seems like a
proactive thing yeah right
like like like you're going to get ahead
of the curve right you're going to
like yeah you need to hydrate you need
to stay hydrated hydrate or die
sure right never heard that hydrate or
die that was like that was the camelbak
remember camelback
yeah that was their expression hydrate
or died like the camelbacks the things
with little hoes coming over yeah oh
that was the oh camel back the brand
they came back the brand had the
expression hydrate or die that's cool
so but let's face it what we're saying
here
and you never hear this he's saying
don't hydrate
if you hydrate too much you're going to
die you're going to run out of water you
need to have water discipline yeah
that's
that's a totally different mindset now
i will tell you when you're going out
along like a desert
patrol where you're not gonna get a
water resupply
you gotta have some water discipline
that makes sense
you know these guys fought when they
needed to have water discipline big time
but
it's interesting to hear that attitude
you don't hear
you don't hear that anymore everyone's
all about hydrate hydrate
it's a different mindset i'm sure maybe
maybe there's some
doctors that will approach us and kind
of give us the real deal on that
yeah well it makes sense because you
have two different scenarios like yeah
if you have the luxury to be able to
just hydrate
at will then oh yeah hydrate or die for
sure but
you know water discipline that idea kind
of seems like it would be
under maybe two specific circumstances
where you don't have
a lot of water just to go have you ever
not had water yes uh yeah yeah yeah
sure where you were almost gonna go down
straight up dehydrated what
happened uh well it was heat uh
exhaustion
okay so the thing is i had water but i
didn't get enough water
okay well what was the scenario football
bruh so there was like a gatorade thing
on the side oh yeah automatic yeah yeah
yes sir
i was not out of water okay my body was
up like
low on water can you get can you get
heat
whatever he can yeah you can you can get
a heat casually while you're drinking
water
yes sir so so you were saying you were
kind of close to that
i guess that's different from just
straight up dehydration well dehydration
is like levels right like you're
they say you're two percent dehydrated
if you're even thirsty for water that's
what they say but so yeah you know it
depends on what you're trying to say you
know
we're going to get some feedback on this
one i can tell you yeah makes sense
but the in you know in the field you're
talking about a situation where there's
two elements where
limited water you don't have unlimited
water because you can't carry unlimited
water
and then you still have to function in
the event of unlimited water
or not and let's face it so there's been
there's been a lot of times where i was
thirsty right in the field
there's one time where i was
in like a little bit of a bad situation
where i could start feeling like oh this
could be a problem
and we were out we were out in the
ozarks
in arkansas doing this big land warfare
problem
and we we were expecting you know we had
planned that you know there were streams
you could see on the map
and there was a couple so we you know
okay we'll be able to go this far and
we'll be able to get water from the
streams and purify it and then we'll go
another distance and we'll get some more
well the first
like two or three streams that we
came across were empty they were dried
up
and so i was running danger close on
water and i'll tell you
not having water to me is the second
the second worst feeling in the world
the worst feeling in the world is
don't don't have air yeah but the thing
is with don't have air that's only a bad
feeling for like
30 seconds and then you're passed down
then you're done
yeah not have water is it takes a while
yeah
so when you try when you go too deep in
the red zone there
it's not like you can just drink water
and get out like air a lot of times like
when you're like let's say you're in the
red zone air but you can still recover
you just take a huge breath and you're
on the road to recovery but water you
get like a for real heat exhaustion
or a heat stroke is death but like heat
exhaustion like a for real one
uh and you drink water you'll just throw
it up yeah because your body can't
really take in that kind of water yet
you got to do the iv thing you got to do
this big process you know so oh yeah
no water that's [__] so i'm sure someone
will contact us and tell us like what
the
there's got to be some minimum protocol
because that's the thing that i have
you know you you gotta have some kind of
minimum protocol like what's the minimum
amount of water you need
yeah i hate being thirsty i would carry
a lot of water
yeah i would carry a lot of water but
you know you know what you just made me
think of you know when you're
caught in a triangle or something or
you're caught in a guillotine and you
get out
yeah and like how good it feels oh it
feels so good
feels so good all right i guess it's
really
triangle triangles are hard to breathe
but like a guillotine
and a ghee choke you're like having a
hard
time breathing yeah because it's like a
good rear naked you know you're not
it's a different you don't feel all
panicky right cause you're still taking
breaths yeah
you're like oh good i'm good good night
you're right about the guillotine there
because
i think there's two elements in the
guillotine defense
that makes you not breathe so like one
it's pressing against your windpipe so
you can't hardly breathe but another one
you're
trying to tense your neck to resist like
that
that torque so when you tense your neck
it's like harder to actually
take a take a deep breath you know it's
like those double things
i've been training with dean list sure
dean lister for
a long time 25 years
he showed me some guillotine defense the
other day and i was like right
you waited 25 years to show me this
guillotine defense yeah i couldn't
guilting him and then he couldn't guilty
show these events i'm like
why wouldn't you show me that why would
you not show me that bro
yeah it's probably like his soul mate
yep and you know what he has so many
things but he also
he just thinks that everybody knows
everything kind of you know so if you
don't ask him about it and the only
reason he was showing someone else
and i'm like what's that defense he goes
oh you just do this here and put this
hand here and i was like
you never showed me that yeah and he was
like oh oh yeah it's real obvious
you feel like an idiot all right so
there you go
water discipline
next i have just been promoted from
first sergeant this is sergeant
major b metzger fifth marines i have
just been promoted from first sergeant
in the fire fighting
the marine first sergeant helps the
company commander
he checks up on the company as a whole
even down to checking
on the evacuation of the wounded i was
able
i was available to the company commander
for any emergency
orders during the firefight teach your
soldiers sir
that when a man is hit in the assault to
leave him there
too many of our men suddenly become
first aid men
your men will have to be rugged and
rough and to win
they must learn to disregard politeness
and must kill
so a couple things there first of all
where i'm going deep on this so first of
all this is what i used to when i used
to teach
when i used to teach the young seals
about leadership i would teach roles and
responsibility for every individual
person
inside of a platoon from a leadership
perspective
fire team leader squad leader platoon
leader
task unit leader company commander level
and the
senior enlisted guy which is the which
is
what he's you know he's he's the company
first sergeant
and what you want to do and the way i
used to explain it to guys and it's the
exact same thing that he's saying
you want to be the action arm for the
leader for the commander
right so the command so so basically
you're the guy with all this experience
but if but if the if something's going
wrong like
you got a problem you got to be the guy
that the company commander can look at
and go
says go solve that problem and you have
the capacity to do it because you're not
assigned any specific role
so you should actually do your best to
keep your comp
to keep your company first sergeant like
free from direct responsibility so that
he can
he can be your action arm to go make
things happen
that's that's number one number two is
prioritize and execute
right everyone wants to help out the
wounded guy you can't
you gotta win first you can't you can't
do that
and then i mean let's face it this
is total war and these guys are just
in a different level you you gotta
disregard politeness and you gotta just
kill people
that's where we're at that's what's so
interesting about
about with the old breed by eugene
sledge
and in the in the hbo series the pacific
they portray eugene sledge he's kind of
like this
very nice very polite guy
that's how they portray him and then you
see videos of the real guy the real
eugene sledge
that's exactly what he's like you know
he's kind of like a southern gentleman
young very nice very kind
and you know those guys were getting
thrown into this
savagery and and that's what this that's
what this that's who this message is for
you gotta disregard politeness
and kill now eugene sledge
we should probably we should probably do
that book again but eugene sledge you
know he had to
he had to put some things in check
himself and he watched guys ripping
japanese soldiers teeth out that were
gold and like
you know pissing on the and he saw crazy
stuff and he had like a line that he
didn't cross over
but he also understood it so even a guy
that's as
nice and and a good of a person which
eugene sledge
apparently was even he
realized like this is this is next level
there's another situation this is normal
platoon sergeant h.r strong company a
fifth marines
some of my men thought their hand
grenades were too heavy
they tossed them aside when no one was
looking later they would have given
six months pay for one hand grenade
there you go short term versus long term
got to carry that little extra weight to
the hand grenade
platoon sergeant f t o farah company b5
marines after the japs had been located
my platoon has gained the element of
surprise by moving in fast with bayonets
and hand grenades
in turn they have surprised us by being
in a defensive position on the reverse
slope of a ridge
i think the snipers look for bar bar men
and then colonel edson said no doubt
about this and one engagement
in one platoon every bar gunner was hit
so
this idea that you could locate them
this is sort of like in jiu jitsu
when you get let's say you get the mount
position you immediately go for the arm
lock
sometimes that's enough to do it right
whereas if you get mount and you're like
okay i got the mount
that person's going into a defensive
position and now they're going to set up
for it
and so what he's saying is if they
locate the japanese
immediately they they go at them with
grenades and bayonets
which the good thing about grenades and
bayonets is now you're they can't really
locate you
because of your because of your muzzle
flashes and where you're shooting
you're just getting in there with
grenades and bayonets
which is you know
you think about modern warfare you don't
think of the tactic of hey when we make
contact we're going to immediately
attack with
bayonets and grenades that's what kind
of war this was
platoon sergeant r.a zolo
company c fifth marines sir i would like
to tell you that that a man's
keenness or dullness of i may determine
whether
or not he will live ten men in my
platoon were killed because they walked
up on a [__]
37 millimeter gun i went up later after
the gun had been put out by our mortars
to help bring back the dead
the japanese gun was so well camouflaged
that i got within
four feet of the gun before i saw it
corporal w.a mccluskey
company d fifth marines sir the other
day on bloody ridge rifleman protecting
our light machine guns pulled out and
left us
we were doing okay at the time but their
pulling out caused our whole
outfit to withdraw
i think the men in the these rifle
companies should receive some training
in the work
and in the mission of the machine gun
company they should be able to act more
intelligently
what does that mean you should have your
team cross train
no matter what business you're in well
no matter what kind of team you have you
should cross train
and the interesting thing about that
we've read that we've read about this
before
when people see other people running
away you've got a pretty good chance
that those people are going to run away
too
this is just mob mentality
second lieutenant andrew chisik fifth
marines
i think that in the regimental supply
there should be extra canteens so when
the
out when an outfit gets in a place like
the table plateau where there is no
water an extra canteen of water can be
issued
sir this would be really this would
really help our men stay in there
and and what's interesting this is all
like done like an interview so that's
why they keep saying things like sir
they're talking directly to this guy and
he's just putting the quotes in there
they're talking to colonel reader
marine gunner e s rust fifth marines i
hate to admit it but it's the truth when
we got here
a lot of our young men were confused at
night they were not used to the jungle
at night
they could not use their compasses at
night and we did not
have enough compasses we have learned
that when we get off the beaten trails
it seems to confuse the japs
and we have better success so what does
that mean you gotta train at night
platoon sergeant jcl hollingsworth
company h fifth marines when we moved
around on these jungle trails we have
learned to have
men at the rear of each platoon who
carry light loads so they can quickly
so they can get their weapons into
action quickly to help overcome ambush
fire from the rear
that's
so what you want to do
as a human as a human that's
strategizing in the world
is you want to have an element that's
flexible and can move quickly to help
you overcome situations
so whether you're in business whether
you
whatever situation you're in you want to
have a specific element that is designed
to move quickly and
give support where it's needed could go
left could go right
could go north could go south could go
east could go west why do you
why do you need that because you can't
predict the future
so you should design your plans so that
the the design of the plans is
inherently flexible
put the big rugged men into the heavy
weapons company
i'm just throwing that out there for all
the young
men going in the military they're going
to saddle you up with that pig gun and
you're going to carry it
from some of our new men were so scared
of our hand grenades when they first
when they were first issued that they
jammed the down the cotter pin
later in action they could not pull the
pin
i noticed as i get and i pointed out
pointed this out to my platoon
that when a man gets hit the men close
by get to yell and corman corman corman
they get so excited sometimes that they
actually forget to use their own first
aid packets
in first aid training teach correct use
of injecting morphine
and procedure of tagging
because what are you gonna do when the
corpsman gets hit
i'd give 75 for a pair of tennis shoes
to rest my feet
and for use in night work
classic
i have only been in the marine corps
four years but i have learned that you
have got to develop a sense of
responsibility in the men wearing
chevrons
right got it you got to develop that
responsibility
in action we have had unauthorized
persons yelling cease firing or commence
firing this caused confusion
platoon sergeant george e
ajo ajo company fifth company f fifth
marines i put five years in the us army
before joining the marine corps sir i
like the marines better than the army
because the average marine officer is
closer to his men than the average army
officer
whom i observed we have comradeship in
the marine corps
also the marine enlisted men are more
spartan-like
i believe sir we baby our soldiers too
much in peace time
i hope we are not doing this now
and then here's a here's a comment from
from colonel reader here
i asked colonel edson what and edson is
the guy that
we read the medal of honor um citation
from i asked colonel edson what kind
of a sergeant aho was and he told me
that he was one of the outstanding men
in his regiment
and that he was a very rugged individual
i heard that i was like i can picture
this dude
you know he gets described as you're in
guadalcanal
with marines and you in that environment
with the toughest bastards in the world
you get you get described as a quote
very rugged individual you know
george e a hoe platoon sergeant company
f
fifth marines doesn't play around
he continues on in our training for this
jungle warfare we had a great deal of
work and hand-to-hand
individual combat use of knife
jiu-jitsu etc let's face it when i read
that i got very very
you know we were feeling good about it
wait what's the year on that 1943
yeah that's uh that's the tradition
jiu-jitsu it's not the president
okay well maybe it is actually because
1925 that's on it
yeah but this is pre-judo no it's not
pre-judo
so it's jujitsu let's let's take it for
what it's worth anyways your
excitement's gonna go down just like
mine did because he says this with the
exception of bayonet fighting
we have not used this work i've been in
many battles since i hit the island
and i've never seen anyone use it okay
so
did some hand-to-hand training oh well
i think maybe just out of sort of gp i
would have
found a way to get my hand to get my
bring the jets
every man should have a watch that's a
good one
just to kind of let you know i mean
think about you're going to
warn you have a watch
our battalion commander major walt wants
every last man in our battalion to know
as much as he does
about the situation it pays
think about that you're in a leadership
position you should try and get
every last man in your team to know as
much as you do about the situation it
will pay
off he also says this get rid of gold
bricks
it's better to be short-handed having
good men around
than having a lot of undependables
you familiar with the term gold brick no
not in this context anyway what context
are you familiar with it in
a regular gold brick which is like a
gold bar
okay got it got it got it so that's the
difference a gold bar
is made of gold a gold brick is a brick
painted like gold
gotcha have you ever seen the big
lebowski yeah
yeah but like once a long time ago
the term is heavily used in there
goldbricker
yep so a gold brick is not it looks like
good
yeah you're just here for show kind of
looks good utility yeah all show no go
all that good exactly man i got a book i
just read for this podcast that we'll be
covering in the future but there's a guy
that shows up in the korean war
and he's all squared away he's all he's
all
like right and tight everything's good
to go and the older combat vets are like
i don't think so and the one younger guy
that's kind of that's a badass that's
actually writing the book
he says oh yeah this guy's going to be
good to go and sure enough the older
veterans
that were looking at him he was suspect
he was
they were suspect because he was like
everything was kind of perfect kind of
like that conversation we had the other
day about
you know music and everything being
perfect and if it's too perfect it's not
real
right well that's kind of the impression
these guys got oh this guy's totally
perfect
well guess what happened when the
bullets started flying he had a
he had a trick knee and all of a sudden
he couldn't
right get after it
so to me that right there gold brick
gotcha
corporal j s stankus company e
fifth marines unnecessary firing gives
your position away and when you give
your position away
here you have to pay for it man i went
on like the
crazy i've gone on crazy change it's
about
giving away your position unnecessary
firing and i'm not talking about combat
i'm talking about
in conversations in leadership
situations
where you give away your position yeah
you take shots at echo echo says you
know i'd like to use this plan over here
and i go that plan doesn't make any
sense
and now all of a sudden you know where i
stand
why would you do that why wouldn't i say
well explain to me more about your plan
and then ask you a question about it
because if i
if i give my position away all of a
sudden you're you're not even you're
already like defensive
i'm causing problems why do that and by
the way you might now attack me because
i just gave my position away now you
might start throwing shots at me
so when you say here's my plan and i say
your plan doesn't make any sense
i just gave my position away i don't
think your plan makes sense there's my
position
whereas if you say here's my plan and i
say why do you want to put guys over
here or why do you want to move this
over here
and you start answering my questions i
haven't given my position away you're
not defensive you're trying to explain
it to me
maybe your plan makes sense but i just
didn't understand it
so don't give your position away not in
guadalcanal and not in the
meeting with your with your team
the men in my squad fire low at the base
of trees there's too much
high firing going on i have i have
observed
japs often get short of ammunition
they cut bamboo and crack it together
to simulate rifle fire to draw our fire
they ain't supermen
they're just tricky bastards
second lieutenant h m davis fifth
marines
in parentheses promoted on the field of
battle
do you understand what that means i
think so
okay so you understand that there's
enlisted guys in the military and
there's officers
yeah so basically the enlisted guys have
not gone to college
the officers well i guess the enlisted
guys may have gone to college especially
nowadays there's a lot of enlisted guys
that have gone to college but the
in these days most likely the enlisted
guy hadn't gone to college
so they went through a regular training
pipeline and you're sort of the
workforce
of the military than the officers
they've been to college
and they've been through some kind of a
training program to make put them into a
leadership position
is that kind of like at a company the
difference between a guy who has a great
uh resume degree blah blah blah comes in
at a certain high position versus the
guy who worked his way up through like
the mail room so
so uh a little bit but let's say
a construction site you've got a guy
that went to college for civil
engineering and he's
he's overseeing the whole project right
and he's oh he got his degree three
years ago
but then you've got a guy that's been
working construction since he was
14 years old and now he's been doing it
for 28 years and he's the foreman
or he's any of those people in between
right right that's that's kind of
the breakout so
to get promoted on the field about a
battlefield promotion
to be get commissioned is
it's pretty powerful that means that
when all this mayhem was going on
they skipped you through like entire
an entire spectrum of
promotions to the next completely
different level
it's hackworth actually in korea got
battlefield promoted like you're so good
we're gonna take you we're gonna put you
in charge yeah
so it'd be like if it'd be like if you
showed up
as the the brick carrier and you did
such a good job and then they
said well you can start putting you did
that and you did something else and the
next thing they promoted you to the guy
that was the civil engineer
put you in charge of the whole project
so that's
so when you hear about second lieutenant
h.m davis
fifth marines promoted on the field of
battle we're talking about
full legit
says travel light for example the hell
with all the mess equipment we used our
mess cup and spoon for the first 15 days
here
and enjoyed our chow
[Laughter]
you don't have to live like a gentleman
in jungle warfare our mess equipment is
too bulky for this type of warfare makes
noise
there you go and then he says this
not every man can lead a battalion
find out who can lead your battalions
before you
go into combat areas
and then colonel edson in parentheses
remark by colonel edson says i would
like to concur
in that statement so the medal of honor
recipient the the commander of that
battalion
he says i'd like to concur with that yep
there's something that's so pure
and just unmercifully beautiful about
combat when it comes to like hey we
cannot we don't we can't afford to play
around
it's kind of cool when i was in in sri
lanka which we covered on
like podcast three or something working
with those soldiers that were fighting
against the
tamil tigers and if they had someone
that was good they'd be like you're
promoted
you're gonna be in charge if they had
someone that bad you're not in charge
anymore they didn't care about anything
there was no
hr department there was no hey we're
gonna document what mistakes you made
and we're gonna counsel you they're like
no
you made like five bad calls in a row
you're done yeah and you
young recruit that's been doing great
you're you're in the game you will put
you in charge it was very cool
and and that's what happens in war it
doesn't so much happen in peace
peacetime
in an advanced and in an advance in the
jungle it's hard for a platoon leader to
keep control of his men
corporals and their men must be taught
to
act individually it's a little something
that we like to call decentralized
command
you are not going to be with everyone
you can't control them it doesn't work
platoon sergeant c m
fagan company if marines
i haven't been fired at many times by
snipers and i haven't seen one yet
i i threw that and there's a lot i
skipped over some of these but there's a
lot of people complaining about snipers
um the sabres which the japanese
officers carry have proved to be
worthless i killed two
japs who came at me with sabers and i
got them first by shooting them
[Laughter]
you remember that scene in indiana jones
yes
you know all scenes what is it which one
uh
some guy comes out and he's swinging a
sword around like kind of a
real skill like hey i got the sword and
we're gonna fight yeah and
and uh indiana jones kind of like shrugs
his shoulder and just pulls a pistol out
and shoots him
that's what i when i heard this i was
like well yeah if you got a gun
he's making a statement hey a gun is
better than a saber
yeah well thank you the we agree
but this isn't new yeah it's kind of
obvious on this the that scene
indiana jones yeah hey you asked for it
so here you go the
uh that scene in real life they were
gonna have
or or the original script or whatever
they were gonna have this epic kind of
battle
sword battle but indiana or harrison
ford had to use a bathroom
real bad so he pulled that out as a
little improv
and they just kept it cool
there you go good to know never mind the
bottle of water canal let's hear about
the
bathroom battles on the set of indiana
jones that's different you know i have a
seat but
uh then he says this but i wished i had
in reserve a good jungle knife
i don't even i don't mean a bolo which
we should have for cutting trails
but a knife with a 12-inch blade of good
steel
we could use this against the these japs
as well as cutting vines that catch us
at night
and then says note many men expressed
their wish
for a jungle knife such as described
here
this desire is being omitted in further
remarks to avoid repetition so
everybody was like give us a big ass
knife
corporal fred carter company if marines
on the river we got to firing at each
other because of careless leadership by
the junior officer so we had a little
blue on blue situation
we are curing ourselves of promiscuous
firing
but i should think new units would get
training to make the men careful
there you go these guys had a little
blue on blue situation
and he's saying i should think new units
would get training to make the men more
careful
yeah that's what i did
when i had a blue on blue friendly fire
situation came back and said
i'm gonna train people so this doesn't
happen to him
we learned not to fire unless we had
something to shoot at doing otherwise
discloses your position in waste
ammunition
he says i have been charged twice by the
japs in bayonet charge
our marines can outbay and not fight
them and i know our army men will do the
same
in the note by colonel edson
incidentally in the last push we
executed
we executed three bayonet charges
sergeant oj marion company l fifth
marines
a platoon guide you crawl in the advance
unless you are to charge and make it
the the reason for this is that all men
hit are hit from the knees up except for
ricochets
we have crawled up to within 25 yards of
a machine gun firing over our backs
the japs don't depress their machine gun
men get killed rushing to help a wounded
man
if the wounded man would crawl about 10
yards to his flank he can generally be
aided in safety
as the japs seem to fire down lanes in
the jungle
colonel edson said we have taught our
men that in the best way to aid a
wounded man is to push ahead
so that the wounded man can be cared for
by the corpsman the men have been
the men have to be trained individually
for when the fire starts the corporal
can't see all of his men
and further when the order for an attack
is given any number of men are unable to
see the man on his right or left
you so you see sir it takes guts for the
men to get up
and move forward when the signal is
given the men have to depend on
on on one another and have confidence in
each other
so again you can see these guys have you
ever been triple girl i guess you have
triple canopy jungle like real thick
jungle yeah
yeah obviously um it's really you can
take five steps and you can't see that
another person
you know and that's what these guys are
seeing for the first time
well not for the first time but they're
seeing hey somebody gets
five feet away from me i can't see them
anymore they have to know how to act on
their own they have to be
ready to utilize decentralized command
he says i was in one advance when the
japs let us come
through and then rose up out of covered
foxholes and shot us in the back
the best cure for that is rearguard
looking towards the rear
corporal ev corporal fr mcallen
company l fifth marines sometimes the
information doesn't get down to us
and then we are really in the dark when
we get the orders and information
we can get in there and pitch better
again
sure you keep your people informed
my platoon is the best one in the
company because we are
all like a baseball team our lieutenant
is like the captain of the team
he is close with us and we like him and
yet respect him
we have a wonderful platoon i'm not
bragging that's a fact
and then here's the note in parentheses
when i read this to colonel edson at the
end of the day
he was so delighted that he sent a
runner to find out who corporal
mcallen's platoon leader was
give that guy a promotion
and here's the interview with colonel
merritt edson himself and again this is
the
this is the guy who received the medal
of honor
that i read at the beginning of this
podcast
he says if i had to train my regiment
over again i would stress
small group training and the training of
the individual
even more than we did when we were in
training
so there you go everyone is stressing
that people need to be able to think for
themselves and make things happen
there must be training in difficult
observation
which is needed for the offense it is my
observation that only five percent of
the men
can really see while observing
yeah what what's crazy about that is
they they do drills especially them in
sniper school where they put like stuff
out in a field like a canteen and a
knife and a notebook they put all this
stuff in a field
and then they give you then they then
they
bring you out to the field and you get
to sit in position you gotta look and
you gotta see
you gotta they've had it kind of hidden
partially hidden so they'll put 10 items
out there and you've got to sit there
with your notebook and you kind of got
to write down all the items that you can
see and what their location is
and somebody that's really and there's
different people have different
levels of skill at actually observing
things so some
some people get oh they get nine they
get eight they get ten some people
see like three or four things so to
actually train for that
is important the other crazy thing about
this is
i was talking about this on ef online
the other day
it's hard it's hard to see and sometimes
things that you think are so obvious
other people aren't seeing and sometimes
if you think what you're doing no one
can see
they can all see it so if you think
you're making some little tactical move
that no one's seeing
you're wrong you're making if you're
making some little maneuver
to get the promotion or whatever and you
think that it's all good no one can see
it
yeah you're wrong everybody can see it
yeah
everybody can see it you know who can't
see it you can't see that they can see
the offensive is the most difficult to
support as you cannot tell exactly where
your troops are
so scary whether the japs will continue
to fight as they do now
i don't know they defend on the low
ground in the jungle
they dig standing trenches extremely
well camouflaged
and he goes into some really like
tactical
level stuff talking about the need for a
rifle grenade the need for a knee mortar
um why that would be good because it
gives the platoon commander kind of at
hand weapons
he says this i suggest that you have
maneuvers with
ball ammunition which is basically do
real bullets and then he says
even if you get a few casualties
i was like dang we now in the seal teams
we do
live fire training all the time and not
only that
we do incredibly complex maneuvers
with live fire
and it it's so beneficial
that you're just used to it you know
you're used to it you really learn about
paying attention and safety and how to
keep your distance and all those
really important things
but if you the the other thing i will
say we got when i first came in the
teams
that's all all we did was live fire and
it was sort of like
the thing you know it's sort of like
that's as good as it gets like
we're doing live fire it was one of
those things and it was
you know you'd go well it's live fire
and we you do so much of it that it
became so it wasn't really
it's just it was just normal right live
fire was just totally normal it's how
you operate
but once we got simunition and like the
the high speed laser tag systems
that's when you got you have to do both
but that's when you got good at actually
combat because
when you're going live fire you're not
going against anyone but paper targets
they don't move but you have to do it
um yeah so he goes into more details
about the kind of boots that they have
and he says the same thing that
everyone's been saying in your training
put your time and emphasis on the squad
and platoon rather than on the company
battalion regiment
so train at the lowest levels your
principle
of the command post up and to the front
is certainly true here
in your scouting and patrolling and your
training in patience
which you should have have the men work
against each other
so he's saying the same thing you have
to do something where you're actually
going against other humans
not just against paper targets same
thing for squads and platoons and their
problems develop better snipers it goes
on to a bunch of things
uh smoking lamp once the smoking lamp
goes out and it gets dark you have to be
quiet
yeah um he goes into this example
in the raiders we adopted the custom of
dropping all rank and titles
we use nicknames for officers all ranks
use these nicknames for us
we did this because the nips caught on
to the names of the officers and would
yell or speak at night
this is captain joe smith talking a
company withdrawal to the next hill
so we adopted nicknames with code words
captain walt became
silent lou my nickname was red mike
an example of the use of these nicknames
as code words is
one night the japs put down smoke and
they yelled gas
we were too green at the time and two of
our companies withdrew
leaving a company exposed on two flanks
he says a value of night training is
that it lets men
learn the normal noises of the woods at
night woods are not silent at night
he says the japanese is no superman he
has the same limitations that we have
they have the advantage of experience
with proper training our americans are
better
as our people can think better as
individuals
encourage your individuals and bring
them out
so this is any team right you either
train your team to think
or you train them to obey and certainly
the japanese leaned toward what they
wanted was obedience
both our riflemen and machine gunners
must be taught to shoot low well i can
tell you that's what i got
taught too shoot low
this leadership business resolves itself
down to being hard-boiled by that i mean
getting rid of the poor leader even if
you like him personally
because this is a life and death affair
this goes right on down to the non-comms
you can see they just did there's no you
could allow no slack for poor leadership
like you know it's peace time i can tell
you when when i first got to the
to the tears bro
the amount of seal officers
that got fired when they were in a seal
platoon was very very small
very small number of seal officers that
would get fired
and then after the war started it would
happen
this is what would happen it was not
like it happened often but it happened a
lot more
happened a lot more because you'd be
looking going
this isn't just a deployment over to you
know train someone or
you know this is going to be we're going
to war um
so that was um that was colonel edson
now we get to major lou walt
commanding officer 2nd battalion 5th
marine
and there's a note from colonel edson
colonel edson told me that major walt
was one of his best leaders and one of
the best men he has
ever seen in action major walt is a
young man
of about 35 years of age he's extremely
rugged
and looks like a fullback on a football
team i talked to him over 20 minutes
before i was able to make a single
original note
as his ideas seem to echo
colonel edson's so that's pretty cool
you got the the battalion commander
saying all the same stuff that the
regimental commander was saying
here's a little report that major luke
walt gives at 6
30 p.m they smoked our two right
companies and when the smoke had
enveloped these two companies
they broke out they came out in mass
formation
20 abreast yelling bayonets fixed
automatic weapons working rear ranks
throwing hand grenades
they were trying to escape to the sand
pit at the mouth of the river in order
to cross the river
to get back our right front company had
just completed a double
apron barbed wire fence when the
japanese hit the left flank of the right
company
they killed nine out of the first 10 men
9 out of the first 11 men they hit
then they hit the barbed wire two of our
heavy machine guns opened up
shooting down along this barbed wire
fence and dispersed their attack
it got dark quickly like it does here
there was smoke
japs and marines all mixed up three [__]
officers were swinging their two-hand
swords
there was hand-to-hand fighting all
night long
we mopped them up at daybreak we killed
japs they killed 12 marines and wounded
26 of us
the [__] has a great deal of respect for
our hand grenade
and is a valuable weapon to us do you
ever practice throwing it in wooded
country
scary throwing grenades in the woods
yeah
because you can hit a tree you can hit a
branch
he says and this is always a common
theme about the japanese the [__] is not
an individual fighter he won't fight
with a bayonet unless backed up with
a dozen other japs
here's where we get to this pure
leadership
as in the basic field manual each
man should know the objective
i make my platoon leader designate an
objective every 100 yards in the jungle
and they work to it and reorganize they
don't push off for the next objective
until they get word from the company
commander this method we have found
ensures control i control my companies
exactly the same way
i set up objectives for each company
when the companies reach their objective
they report after the reorganization we
go ahead
i think reserves and the attack should
be kept up close so they can be
committed
immediately
platoon sergeant c c ardent
[Music]
and there's a note in here it says when
when colonel edson
sent for his best fighters he did not
include platoon sergeant ardent
after i got through talking to these men
two of them came up to me and said sir
did you did not see sergeant arden he
has
more patrols and does more scouting than
any man in the regiment
could we get him for you sir and so here
we go
cece ardent and he seems like the kind
of guy when i was reading this i was
like i know this kind of dude
so here's this this dude i practice
walking quietly over rocks twigs grass
leaves
through vines etc i practiced this
around the bivouac area
i received instructions in scouting and
patrolling in quantico
but i still practice this around here in
the biviwack area
i believe because i practice this is the
reason i am still alive
some of the other ncos laughed at me
because i'm always
seeing how quietly i can walk around
because i go out and practice on my own
but they have stopped laughing because i
have been on more patrols than any man
in the regiment
and i am still alive when i am scouting
and come to an opening in the jungle and
have to cross it i generally run across
it quickly and quietly
going slow here may cost a scout his
life
different types of terrain calls for
different methods
so i totally know that guy
just obsessed and i love it
go ahead you thinking like the like
jiu-jitsu guys do that too you know you
know guys
like they stand up and they do like a
technical stand even though you know
they're just doing they're keeping it
real yeah yeah or when they give you a
hug they like
fish for underhooks like they're always
doing that thing
you know yeah yeah but i think this is
the guy that's like
stan you know not just that this is the
guy that's
and and you know i when i when i first
got in
and actually the whole time i was in it
was like okay i got to do this again i
need to do this better i gotta get
better at this
but i i i did that kind of in a broad
way right like
like i kind of wanted to be good at
everything you know
whereas it'd be like someone whereas
there's some guys that would get really
into one thing yeah you know it'd be
like someone that just
works on you know deep half guard
they just get obsessed with deep pap
card and that's what they're working on
like that's all they're drilling that's
all they're doing
this is colonel amore
l e r sims
commanding officer seventh marines first
marine division
and he says is the army stripping down
to essentials and equipment
teach not to waste ammunition learn to
make every shot count
try to get the japs on the move keep
them bouncing around don't let them get
set
when you let them get set they're hard
to get out this is such a good
philosophy to have
whenever you're in a competitive moment
against another person
or against another business or against
another team don't let them settle don't
let them
you know like we talked about earlier
you get them out and go for the unlock
look sometimes you think well get there
an established position
i get it i get that philosophy
but if you can and you can get there and
you can go for it you're gonna catch
them off guard
don't let them prepare go
he says our battalion commanders in the
seventh marines
know that in reporting information at
once
and if they need help to ask for it and
not just try to
pull things through that they are
enabling regiments to act as a team
in the right manner and in the right
direction so he's saying listen
the battalion commanders knew that they
needed to get the information the
correct information
up the chain of command as quickly as
they could so that they so that the
chain of command
the senior leadership could support them
and if you needed help you needed to ask
for it
a regimental commander cannot be
impatient
don't push your battalion commanders
unless you feel there is reluctancy
on their part our great leader general
van de grift gives me a job and
lets me handle the situation with a
regiment in my
own way he is not impatient with me
impatience would ruin the best plans
a mapped plan may not turn out to be
feasible
so we have learned here not to be
impatient
and then he says it has been impressed
upon us here
that the logistics have to be correctly
planned
the science of logistics turns out to be
your life logistics wins wars
here's a thought i would like to leave
you with the regimental commanders
pick your officers for common sense
basic field manual knowledge is fine
but it is useless without common sense
common sense is of greater value
than all the words in the book
i am too deep so that's a statement
right there right common sense
isn't that amazing
promote and put in leadership positions
people that have common sense
then he says i am too deep in my
battalions in regard to battalion
commanding officers that is each one of
my battalion executive officers
is a potential battalion commander the
reason for this is if the
battalion commander gets killed or sick
i won't be caught out on a limb
he says i make my staff officers get out
of this cp
not to snoop so they go get out of the
command cup post and go to the front
lines
and he does that quote not to snoop on
the troops but to help the battalions
and equate themselves with the general
situation
insist on night training but don't train
day
and night if i were training my regiment
again working seven days a week
i would train three nights and four days
our orders to our marines on the
perimeter defense are
this is this is kind of epic our orders
to our marines
on the perimeter defense are you stay on
your position and do not pull back
if they bust through you will plug up
the hole but you
stay there
and then he says this regiment can out
yell the japs
out fight them out bayonet them and out
shoot them
this yelling as in hand-to-hand action
is important
it's like a football team that talks it
up
the japs yell at us marines we're gonna
kill you
more blood for the emperor the marines
yell back
you blank blankety blank blank blankets
and it just has blood
that's little underlying you blank
blankety blank blank we'll kill you japs
more blood for franklin
they're just yelling at each other
you know that was like when we had
cowboy on
and cowboy could hear the north
vietnamese army commander
yelling hey get ready to get ready to uh
assault and he's telling telling lynn
black
here they come he just gave the order to
assault
sometimes that's how right like if
you're close i think it was
life who said when they were like in a
gunfight and they were so close they
were
they were yelling at each other well you
could definitely hear
people talking yeah yeah i saw a video i
have to ask leif like what particular
instance that was
yeah he i saw a video it was online
of uh some fights from army guys i think
in afghanistan they're kind it looked
like a kind of a jungle
there's parts of afghanistan that look
like that yeah like not a thick yeah you
know but like it was like trees in there
and they were in a gunfight and they
were you could hear them
yelling at you and i think you there it
was in a different language and stuff
and they're just
the same deal blankety blank blank but
it's crazy because in football yeah
that's how too yeah you know it's like
it's all talking trash the whole time
yeah even the referee is saying hey be
quiet be quiet
no fat the referee is no factor because
you can't do nothing for you he's
talking
and everyone's yelling at each other
right and depends certain teams are more
hostile than others
whatever um just depends on the
personality of the team
but yeah that goes on but it's all like
it's all within like sportsmen like
you know some of it's funny some some of
it's like kind of
you know so there's there's a certain
it's kind of the culture you know
but it's crazy to understand that like
this guy's trying to straight up
kill you and you're trying to kill them
so that blankety blank blank is like the
real deal you know
damn this next section
is about the commanding officer of the
first battalion
seventh regiment us marines first marine
division you might know who that is it's
lieutenant colonel
louis b puller from podcast
121 we went through his book which is
called marine
in podcast 122 we talked about his son
lewis puller jr
so if you want to check out those
podcasts there is
that's a podcast that will stay with you
i'll put it to you that way
um so what he says this is one of the
most
yeah this is the most iconic marine of
all time
chesty puller and he says
and this was kind of cool because like
this is
it's cool because the way this is
written you can tell that this guy was
taking notes like there was someone
there sitting there writing down word
for word what these guys were saying so
this is chesty puller talking
and he says in handling my companies i
take the company commander's word for
what is going on
you have to do this to get anywhere in
order to get a true picture of what is
going on
in this heavy country i take my staff
i make my staff get up to where the
fighting is
this command post business will ruin the
american army and marines if it isn't
watched
hell our platoons and squads would like
a command post in the attack
if they are not watched
as soon as you set up a command post all
forward movement
stops
[Music]
that's a good one it's a good one to
think about mentally
for you for us for me
right you as soon as you set up a
command post like okay i'm good
i'm good in this spot forward progress
stops
don't do it he says the walkie-talkie
that japs have
operates why why can't we have a similar
one
and then he says this to hell with the
telephone wire advancing with the troops
we can't carry enough wire we received
an order
this advance the advance will stop until
the wire gets in
this is backwards
[Music]
so you know because they didn't have
good radio communications
they they would run a wire an actual
wire so they could
talk to each other on these little field
telephones
well obviously it's not easy to run that
wire out there and you'd see
you ever seen vid you know movies of
guys they got the little wire and reel
they're running out avoiding getting
shot i mean it's a total nightmare
but then you get these commanders saying
hey don't advance anymore until you get
the wiring position
and chest he's like look we know where
we're going
let us go he said the staffs are twice
as large as they should be
the regimental staff is too large i have
five staff officers in the battalion
and i could get along with less the
officers have to dress and look like the
men
one time the commandant of the marine
corps asked me why our patrols failed in
haiti
i replied because of the officer's
bedding role in haiti at that
time the officer had to have a pack mule
and the enlisted men
saw the officers lying around in luxury
the patrols were actually held up for
this pack mule
your leaders have to be up front those
that won't get up there
and are not in physical shape to keep up
with the men
will cause plans to fail
it's okay to say that an outfit cannot
be surprised
but it is bound to happen in this type
of warfare so
therefore your outfits must know
what to do when ambushed so he's saying
like hey look you can say hey we're not
going to get surprised but guess what
you are so you better know what to do
then he says calling back commanding
officers to battalion and regimental
uh cps to say how are things going
is awful that's a statement that's a
complete statement if you call me back
from the front line to say how's it
going
it's awful each company is responsible
for its flank this is a time tested and
proven formation which worked if
attacked from the flank
face and adjust the good little
good little thing to think about
in marching or in camp i just noticed
like now that i'm reading chesty puller
i'm getting more fired up
i'm channeling chesty in marching or in
camp
i think i'm doing what i think he
sounded like in marching or in camp
we've learned here that you must have an
all-around defense
there you go he's just making statements
he's not even
he's just he's just rattling things off
we need more entrenching shovels
give shovels to the men who have wire
cutters you need both the wire cutter
and shovels
i wish we had had the m1 rifle and when
we get relieved from guadalcanal i'm
going to make every
effort to get it
i consider it my imperative that the
army and marines be equipped with knee
mortars
and only carry one type grenade have the
hand grenade fit in the knee mortar
and be of use as a hand grenade and also
as a rifle grenade you need a rifle
grenadier and each squad for use
against enemy machine gun nests
i did in some of the other guys i kind
of skip through uh some of their
when it gets re it starts getting real
granular but i wasn't going to skip
chesty puller because because
chesty puller
the following is the result and so
that's it that's that's
uh what we get from chesty but then the
following is the result of a conference
with five of the best
ncos in the first battalion or the
seventh marines these ncos were selected
by lieutenant colonel polar here's some
comments from them the japanese fire is
not always aimed it is harassing fire
and scares
recruits get the recruits so they are
used to overhead fire
japs who have infiltrated signal to each
other
with their rifles by the number of shots
we get these birds by constantly
patrolling
he says if one of the guys say if you
shoot their officers they mill around
talking about the japanese if you shoot
their officers they mill around
their ncos are poor you can tell their
officers by their sabers
and their letter leather plates which is
like some kind of legging
i had to look that word up plateaus
p-u-t-t-e-e-s
it's like a legging but this is again
this is something that you hear a lot
about the japanese is that
once their officers are dead they
because they're
very centralized command micromanaged so
if you killed their if you killed their
officers all of a sudden the
the rest of the troops are just kind of
milling around they don't know what to
do
lieutenant shepard seventh marines also
promoted on the field of battle
we salute you lieutenant shepard
i would stress in training teamwork
between the leaders and all units
liaison between support plans and all
leaders liaison between artillery and
the infantry
if i were training my unit again i would
really have some high class patrol
training
i would do everything with these patrols
i could possibly think of to include
losing them
and making them go across country
without maps or compasses
the japanese do a lot of yelling at
times and other times they are deadly
silent
one night some japanese got in our
marching column
we discovered them and bayonetted them
at another time i heard i myself heard a
japanese yell in good english
k company forward
the japs don't like our men yelling back
at them
okay next we get to master gunnery
sergeant r.m
foul seventh marines and he's 24 years
of service
he said we learned not to get excited or
go off half cocked where there's noise
the japanese make noise to mislead us
they shot off some firecrackers at the
start but we have learned
that where the noise is he ain't
you never hear him move he sleeps in the
daytime and does his work at night
officers and ncos during shelling should
move around and talk to the men
quiet them down if you don't do this
some of them will walk around with their
fingers on their triggers and they get
to imagining things
and along this line we learned to post
double sentinels
one man to quiet another sheesh
imagine that you gotta you gotta put two
people on watch because you got one of
them's gonna freak out
all my time in the marines i've seen men
bunch up
and i've talked about this and make my
ncos talk about this all the time
the men seem to fear separation i talked
about that in leadership strategy and
tactics i got a whole section called
don't botch up
and i don't didn't just talk about it
from the battlefield perspective but
what happens is
the way i the reason i had to talk about
it in there is because yes people bunch
up on the battlefield and they do it
because they're
they're afraid and because you want to
hear you want to be close like
i want to get to you to hear what you
have what's going on but what happens in
from a leadership perspective is people
bunch up mentally in
from the lead so echo you have an idea i
like to crowd in with your id and put my
ideas in there we
all want to get together we want to talk
we got to give our input it's like man
give that person some space let that
plan develop a little bit don't bunch up
don't crowd it
this one says the japs are man monkeys
and they run around considerable in
order to compete with these man monkeys
from japan
you got to be in excellent shape and
you've got to be tough
we can lick them and we are doing it all
the time sir so
yeah you're saying they're like in great
shape and they're able to move around
through the jungle very quickly
well i suppose it's like when uh when
joe rogan
calls some fighter like a gorilla
or whatever right yeah or a monster yeah
monster animal
yeah the animal check
man monkeys lieutenant colonel frisbee
executive officer 7th marines
i hope the army is being toughened up we
toughened up
by bivouacking not camping at the combat
ranges
we lived at these combat ranges in order
to teach platoons to keep off the road
we made platoons march in the field
alongside the road
when they moved from one combat area to
another
hey what's bibiwacking um
sleeping in the woods
not camping but you know setting up a
small area to sleep in you're not like
put pitching a tent
it's like a uh
just a makeshift sort of we're gonna
sleep here
like not even at camp like less so just
kind of for sleeping for rest yeah it's
not like in a
bad way or a necessarily a good way more
just like
to get sleep like hey we've been
patrolling all right we're in a good
spot hey we're gonna be
wack here for the night okay you know
half guys on security other half guys
get
you know put your head down get some
sleep gotcha
probably a good defensible position
here's lieutenant colonel n h
han khan
second battalion seventh marines and by
the way medal of honor
from haiti it pays in the attack in the
jungle to use the heavy machine
guns there is a difference of opinion as
you have noticed
on this matter it's hard work yes but
don't
overlook the value morale and otherwise
and don't forget about the high rate of
fire if you ditch the heavy machine guns
and substitute
the lights in their place you must
remember that you will be up against the
japanese machine guns
as we all know i'm a huge fan of machine
guns yes sir and
apparently so is lieutenant colonel be
careful about withdrawing the men unless
all the men
know what it's about if you don't do
this you're liable to make the man
panicky we already talked about that
mob mentality can happen you must
realize that there is such a thing as
not attacking when ordered to do so
we have got to get to a point where the
men go ahead when ordered
and damn the hindmost corporals must be
indoctrinated with leadership to
overcome this
and all ranks have got to have
the hate
like i said this is a different time man
you're going against a different enemy
we're talking about you have to hate
the enemy that's where we're at
[Music]
here's a conference with three second
lieutenants and five
old ncos of 2nd battalion 7th marines
the basic principle of leadership in the
u.s marine corps is that the individual
is told of his responsibility
in different situations and is held to
it
you got to have confidence in each other
when signals to move forward are given
you must have confidence that the men
next to you will move forward
even if you cannot see them we have that
kind of confidence in this battalion
there's a quote here which i am in full
agreement
with it says we love the heavy machine
gun
period
we have two american indians we use as
talkers on the telephone or
voice radio when we want to transmit
secret or important messages
it's awesome be mean
and kill em kill him dead our platoon
our motto in this platoon is no
prisoners
second lieutenant d a clark 7th marines
promoted on the field of battle this
officer was interviewed in the hospital
where he was recuperating from wounds
we have a lot of trouble in my platoon
with water discipline
we also have trouble with men bunching
up in order to talk to each other
they seem to do this even though it
means death
major abuse assistant g3 on the gen
on general van der griff staff we have
had to multiply
our unit of fire in hand grenades by
five
[Music]
the yellow color on hand grenades is
poor
why can't they just be painted black as
the yellow
color enables the japs to throw them
back you ever seen that color
combination
it's it's in a very it's very common in
the military it's like an olive drab
but then the writing is in yellow yeah
and like even the grades no one listened
to this guy because the grenades still
have like a yellow band around them
it's it's it's not like a bright yellow
but it's definitely a yellow
yeah wait why is that why is it yellow
that's just how they mark them i mean
there's no particular reason
it looks kind of dope i almost actually
leadership strategy and tactics
i almost went in fact the reason i
didn't go because this olive drab
the reason i didn't go that same exact
yellow is because you couldn't really
read it clearly enough
yeah that's kind of a bummer i should
have just stuck with it huh yeah
like claymore might do claymore mines
are they yellow it says front towards
enemy yeah actually
yeah yellow mar i think yeah yeah so
it's very
it's a common thing it's the common
stencil color
is this olive drab green and it's a
faded yellow
it's like a drab yellow
he says this i am being sent back for a
rest we have been in action continually
here from august 7 1942 until this date
november 26 1942
what we all marvel at is how general van
de grift can stand it so much better
than we do
it must be his character
we'll have to do like a full-on podcast
on general van der griff
major ben j northridge co second
battalion
164th infantry
if i could train my men over again i
would put officers
and men in slit trenches and drop bombs
nearby to overcome fear
we were all scared to death at first
let's overcome this fear
how about firing some captured 25
caliber ammunition out of captured
rifles to let officers and men know the
sound
also captured [__] machine guns
ammunition
out of their captured machine guns got
to get used to that
sound luckily we do i mean luckily we
have ak-47 so we can do that
no problem no factor we know what that
ak sounds like
lieutenant colonel frank richards ceo
1st battalion 164th infantry
he says if i were training my battalion
again i would have training
in patience
i would have patrols wait for the enemy
to expose himself
they move around too they have to
relieve themselves
and they have to get food i would have
the men
in this patient's training made be made
to sit still
for hours at a time
captain john a gossett ceo
company h 164th infantry teach the men
the capacities
of the hand grenade and handling men
and that crazy dude that this guy is
here in guadalcanal and here's the two
notes that he's got he says you gotta
learn the capacities of hand grenades
and how to handle men i thought i knew
how to handle men
but since i've been here i have revised
my ideas as i have learned a great deal
i have learned the primitive rough and
tumble way
you can't pat all men on the back you
have to be rough with some men in order
to get results
it is not my nature to be rough but i am
forcing myself
and i have learned which of my men i can
pat on the back
and which i have to deal with in the
hardest manner
everyone's the same everyone's different
captain john a dawson commanding officer
company b 164th infantry
if i could train my company again i
would have
some maneuvers on which the men were
deprived of food
water and comforts in order to find out
which ncos and men can't
take it i would relieve these people
this type of maneuver would teach men to
know and expect
hardships it will lessen the shock when
they come up against the real thing
in the presence of the enemy
it is important that the entire squad
know how to operate
the bar not just two men reason think of
the bar men who are wounded
get killed and become sick and have to
be evacuated
again cross training
lieutenant john s graves platoon leader
company
c 164th infantry the biggest thing i
have learned since i hit this island is
that leadership and initiative
is so important here the platoon leader
can only be in one spot at a time
and men must be trained to act correctly
on their
own i've never seen this type of
training
yes decentralized command
that's just post that on your brain
sergeant w.v damas squad leader company
c
164th infantry sir i would like to say
that there is no place for recruits here
we need trained soldiers who have
initiative
and and know what is the right thing to
do
the jungle is so thick that squad
leaders cannot get around
all of the time to see men and tell them
what to do this is the common theme
this is colonel b e moore commanding
officer 164th infantry
note when i saw colonel moore he was
interviewing a patrol and patrol leader
who had just come back
they had been on a reconnaissance for 15
hours the patrol leader had been
met at an advanced position and
as he had valuable information of the
enemy
he was conducted by jeep to the
observation post of the artillery where
he directed artillery fire
then returned to the colonel where he
made his report
the patrol and its leader were nearly
exhausted
colonel moore had on hand
a small sample bottle of brandy
which he issued one small sample bottle
to each two men
he made them dilute this brandy with
water in their canteen cups
it was noticeable that this helped them
the following interview took place after
the patrol had been dismissed
one could not be around colonel mar
colonel moore very long
without realizing that he is a leader
and regimental commander in every sense
of the word
taking care of his people
and he says the greatest problem is
leaders
and you have to find some way to weed
out the weak ones
the platoon leaders who cannot command
who cannot foresee things
and you cannot act on the spur of the
moment in an emergency
are a distinct detriment
leadership and this is the
last thing we're going to read from this
book
he says many of the junior leaders have
not used their heads at times in their
training i recommend
you put them up against situations
where they must use their heads
he says the good leaders seem to get
killed the poor leaders get the men
killed
the big problem is leadership and
getting the shoulder straps on the right
people
not one man and 50 can lead a patrol in
the jungle
if you can find out who the good patrol
leaders are before you hit the combat
zone
you have found out something i have had
to get rid of about
25 officers because they just
weren't leaders i had to make the
battalion commander
weed out the poor junior leaders this
process is continuous
our junior leaders are finding out that
they must know
more about their men
the good leaders know their
men
the good leaders know they're men
obviously that's not new
we've heard it before in fact we've
heard all this before
and what's crazy is they'd all heard it
before
right like these principles have been
around
these principals been around forever but
they still made mistakes
they still had to relearn those lessons
and they still had to make
every effort
like this manual to pass those lessons
on
and what should we do we well what we
should do is we should make
our best effort to receive those lessons
remember those lessons
just as we should remember these brave
men
who learn these lessons in blood
what do you got echo charles you know
i always like so there's kind of two
ways you can go with
like all of this stuff where it's like
you hear it over and over and over again
right
which should sort of reinforce it so you
kind of got to be careful
to not regard it i guess maybe this
happens subconsciously sometimes where
you just
you know you hear something over and
over again and then it just becomes sort
of just noise like i already know that
you know what's weird about me
yeah i know a lot of things
when you say that like i can't relate to
it yeah because every time i hear these
things
i'm like there it is yep yeah i'm like
there it is it's a reinforcement
it's it's it's i'm hearing it again it's
a little bit of different angle but i
know what that means
you know like that last little section
it's so crazy to read that
it's so crazy to read that this guy's
saying in training you
i recommend you put them in situations
where they must use their heads
i teach that all the time at echelon
front we were like oh you want to train
your leaders you got to put
you can't give your leaders problems
that there is a rote
memorizable solution to you actually
want to make them think
i always bring up a story with the
germans the germans would give
their subordinate leaders in training
they would give them
problems that could only be solved if
they broke the rules
which means there's no format to what
they're getting them to try and do
so how can you get your people you need
to put your people in situations where
they need to think so every time i look
and this is lessons that i've taught
before
but i hear it i'm like there it is yeah
maybe because you like
apply it so maybe often or maybe it made
like such an impact for
because of like your experiences and
stuff or maybe both i don't know but
so it's always sticking with you so
you're always like looking to like
reinforce
to make it better to improve on this
very thing that you're actually
practicing
yeah you know what's interesting so my
last three years in the in the
i was running that training so i got to
see and i always say that the training
that i ran
was the best leadership laboratory
in the history of the world and i would
be willing to go toe-to-toe on anyone
that thinks that they've seen him better
i will not not not to fight him but i
would be interested
if there was someone else that says oh
we did we had a leadership
situation where this is what we got to
see
and therefore we have a really good
understanding of
of leadership as well i'm sure there's
other things that are out there
i'm telling you the when i was running
that training
it was freaking awesome because you're
seeing
platoon after platoon after platoon
after platoon with different leadership
you could see the good leadership versus
the bad leadership you see what worked
what didn't work
it was the best leadership laboratory
and i
i i learned but i got to take the
lessons that i learned
and see them applied and when they when
they applied them well
did things would go well if they didn't
apply them well things would go bad
so obvious it was so obvious and what's
interesting is now
at echelon front i kind of get to do the
same thing
because it's hey i work with a business
here's what's happening in their market
here's what's happening in their
expansion here's what's happening as
they grow
so we get to see oh here's the
leadership here's what you need to do
and then i it's like this is the mistake
that you're making this is where you
need to move
and so i like you said i i'm very lucky
because i continue to get to work
directly in this environment that i've
been completely
and utterly engaged in
for you know i mean for a long long for
decades
and and and yet that i guess maybe
that's why when i see these things
i think to myself like yes
like i get it just just more
reinforcement
and yeah so do you like it
what like straight up like okay so we'll
we'll call this
maybe oversimplify simplifying it
leadership
right do i like it yeah are you serious
right now oh yeah man you got it
i absolutely love it okay i love it and
you know what i love it in the way that
what i love about it is it is a
continual
challenge to it's it's it's
it's solving a problem and getting the
grass it's kind of like jiu jitsu and
that
you get out there you learn a move you
see a move you use the move it works it
doesn't work you make adjustments on it
it's a very similar
thing but yeah i love it because
it's super complex and yet it's super
simple
right and the gratification
is is extraordinary because
people you know like people say
i did what you just told me to do you
know i did it in the last meeting
and fred's on board now and you're like
well that's awesome
yeah and and this was a problem for
someone
that was a legitimate not just a
challenge but like a threat to
their lifestyle right a threat to their
business a threat to their
corporation and you're like hey here's
this
here's okay do this report back let me
hear what you got
okay here's the report okay here's the
reaction i got okay good that means
continue moving this
oh no that means go over in this
direction so to be able to
to be able to be lucky enough to take
all these
lessons that i learned and be able to
apply them
on a daily basis it's ridiculous
it's freaking awesome because like it's
do you like leadership well i i knew the
answer and
maybe it was kind of a semi-rhetorical
question but
uh if because some people they don't
they don't like it they they see it as a
necessity and stuff like that but they
don't really like it
so and then it's a spectrum for sure
it's like sales you know
like sales for example where some people
they just love it and every little tip
every little
thing every little like established
like element of successful stuff they're
all up
all about it no well people can be into
all kinds of stuff right yeah
jiu-jitsu guitar drawing oh yeah
reading i mean yeah so if there's a
certain philosophical element
that has like with stood the test of
time
and they're reading it here reading that
man it's going to reinforce their thing
they're going to be into it
and it's going to be just in their head
they're going to apply it any chance
that they get
even if it's this much of a little
development they're going to apply it
boom it's ready it's down because they
enjoy it and that's part of their jam
but
if let's say you don't really like it
it's like a like a
chore or whatever right you know there's
certain type
introvert type people who are in a
leadership position who kind of don't
like it
they'd rather someone else deal with the
people or something like this for sure
and then so those are the ones that
might be i don't know
but they might be the ones that are
going to be making these mistakes over
and over again because they're not
consciously like actively trying to
implement these lessons that are just in
someone like your case just straight up
being reinforced
yeah but for them it's it's almost like
not even getting in it's kind of like
yeah i heard that before whatever
i heard that before whatever i'm too
busy like not caring almost in a way
like i'm too busy like caring about the
things that i care about and like yeah i
think i think where
oh there's a lot of misconceptions and i
i wrote about this in leadership
strategy and tactics but here
it's it's on like the cover flap or
whatever
um leadership is the most challenging
of human endeavors it is often
misunderstood
it can be bewildered mystify and
frustrate even the most
dedicated practitioners leaders at all
levels are often forced to use
theoretical guesswork to make decisions
and lead their troops
it doesn't have to be that way there are
principles that can be applied and
tenets that can be followed
there are skills that can be learned and
maneuvers that can be practiced and
executed
there are leadership strategies and
tactics that have been tested and proven
on the battlefield in business and in
life
so that's what i think people miss out
on is they miss out on the fact that
it's not
it's it's kind of like any
any skill set that you want to learn
you want to learn how to play guitar
you've got to
learn the chords you've got to learn
notes you want to learn jiu jitsu you
got to learn an arm lock you got to
you want to learn how to play basketball
you got to learn how to dribble you
couldn't expect why would anybody expect
that they could walk out on a basketball
court without ever practicing and be
good at it
now what now let me ask you this have
you ever watched
uh some like a skateboarder
or a bmx guy or a mountain biker
or a surfer and been like oh that looks
you you think in your weird mind that
you could actually do what they're doing
right yeah not the skateboarding guys
but yeah the other guys yes
guys are crazy but but you think oh like
oh like
i can see myself doing that so i think
people look at leadership sometimes and
there's things that are happening
oh yeah i would do the same thing or
whatever it looks easier than it is
yeah and so you have to be careful of
that and maybe that's why i
continue to enjoy reading
and learning about it because i see
how hard it is i see every day what a
challenge it is for people
so if i can take one thing away from a
book that i can use as a tool to help
someone else
maneuver through a challenging
leadership situation i i
love it i love adding that capability
yeah yeah makes sense to me
so speaking of learning and improving
and getting better
uh what other suggestions might you have
for us
i do mister yeah kinda like me echo
zane charles it's kind of like me saying
hey
exercise will help improve every other
aspect of your life true
unlike any other thing or whatever sure
that thing sure i'll say it over and
over again
whatever it helps reinforce it
hopefully hopefully it doesn't become
noise oh yeah
i will give you some credit right now
for taking what i just said which is um
it was a pretty meaningful moment and
what you just said is you're going to
continue to read the same stuff over and
over again
on the porch section of the podcast
what's good for the goose is good for
the the other guy you don't understand
what i'm saying anyway we're working out
that's going to improve your life mm-hmm
health fitness what if you just tried to
say things in a different way sometime
like maybe people would be more
interested in it
it's possible it's possible uh
nonetheless we are still working out
regardless i always say it
yeah i worked out today did spots what
oh
good job i had pull-ups today
by the way we're in the process of the
let's call it the new garage gym of
justice we are probably two months out
maybe right now so we're getting there
really yeah if anybody if anybody
you know uh maybe a year and a half ago
there was a transition
where i was i moved into a temporary
holding facility for myself
that meant a temporary workout facility
in my home and that was all
a strategic move to long term have a
much
better sort of facility
facility improved yes so we're getting
there i'm looking forward to
unveiling that i might even do you know
the um i'll get people that say hey show
us your gym yeah gym tour like jim tour
i'll tell you what i will when i when
the new
gym is complete or at least like when
it's kind of
getting close we'll do a little we'll do
a little um
facility tour yeah so you're thinking
so what are you to do or you're saying a
month or two more months
two months ish maybe maybe three maybe
two and a half no maybe two
okay we should we're getting there we're
getting close we're getting close
so improvements across the board
straight up facilities
personal health all that stuff that's
good and important that's what we're
looking for is what we're going for
anyway
we've got supplements for you if you if
you need them which
you don't need you know that's a
spectrum but these things will
100 help you yeah i'm gonna go ahead and
said
say that you pro you need you need to
get joint warfare and krill oil
for sure yeah i'm not sure of it well if
you're listening this podcast which
means you're getting after it
right okay if you're not listening to
this which we don't care
you're then you don't need it right sure
you legitimately don't because you're
like on your own program you're probably
watching tv you don't need joint warfare
and super krill
if you're to to strengthen your thumb to
press the remote
control yeah you're not a little bit
different yeah you can just get
whatever more more french fries more
cheetos
that's what you can get yeah if you're
in the game you may want to get
super krill you may want yeah you should
you need to get
super curl you need to get joint warfare
and the reason i say need is because
if you don't take it you have issues you
will have
issues that's it don't just get get away
from the issues
yeah yeah it's like one of those things
like you ever play uh you played soccer
before
right soccer baseball football right you
wear certain kind of shoes called cleats
really cleats so
when you when you go play when you suit
up you put on your cleats
you don't put on tennis shoes no i mean
look is it possible to put on tennis
shoes
do you need cleat that's the thing do
you need cleats depends on what you
might need right exactly and that's
exactly what i'm saying okay so
clarification accepted look look if you
want to stay on this path
and not worry about your joints giving
out on you and they can
oh they can get give out on you for sure
they can bother you
ache they can ache when you're not even
exercising straight up they can
but if you don't want to worry about
that kind of stuff that's when you take
the joint warfare and the super krill
oil
100 just take it every day like i do
every single day
so far since our last talk anyway i'm
glad you've tightened it up
yes sir also discipline
and discipline go kind of the same thing
just different uh delivery
different modalities of delivery yes sir
big time so yeah
oh you know the powder there's the
powder there's the pill there's the
energy drink i'm just call it energy
drink
healthy energy even though it's barely
related to the common what's commonly
considered an energy drink
is it when i think of energy drink i
think oh massive amount of sugar
massive amount of caffeine massive
amount of chemicals yeah
to keep it from going getting spoiled
that's what i think of when i think of
an energy drink
and i think of a pink orange and yellow
can that it's in yeah silver maybe
yeah that's what i think of yeah so
that's an energy drink now it is very
strange to say
that what we have which has
no sugar it's sweetened with monk fruit
it's got 95 milligrams of caffeine so
it's got caffeine in it but that's the
same as a cup of coffee it's not some
crazy amount that gets you all
psycho jittery and you have a big crash
from
and there's no preservatives in it
because we pasteurize it
so what we're really talking about are
two totally different things
one of them has a bunch of bad stuff in
it the other one has a bunch of good
stuff in it
yes so so why are they both called
energy drinks
i'm not 100 sure one of them should be
called an energy drink
the other one should be called poison
next question not to get too analytical
on here but i think i know why
because you and you know some of us
we think of energy drinks not as what
the whole energy drink we just think of
the stigma
not just the stigma but the stigma is a
very significant portion
and rightly so by the way put some if
there's some
stuff that's straight up bad for you
that should mean something yeah that's
what i think
yeah so you know you think about those
kind of things and rightly so like i
said
but you know you know they're like
hippie people that will say like oh
that's bad energy
yeah that's different so now i'm kind of
feeling like there's such a thing as
like bad energy drinks
that drink has bad energy we got the
good energy and
the clean energy to me that's in play
too i think so
so you know if you consider the stigma
of energy drinks and it's not an
unfair stigma it's not it's fair it's
accurate it's a fair stigma
if you consider that and you associate
it with the word energy drink
yes when you look at choco discipline go
citrus psycho jocko all these flavors if
you look at that
then yeah they're not going to be very
similar in that way
because we don't have the stigma over
here no stigma energy drink without the
stigma how about that there you go there
you go boom look at that one
on go to jackalfuel.com you like that
one
yes sir chocofuel.com that's where you
can get it that's that's part of origin
main yeah
i'm talking kind of the same deal you
can also get them at wawa the energy
drinks
the stigma the unstigma stigma-less
energy drink at wawa and the vitamin
chop as well
also milk milk don't forget about milk
vitamin d
three cold war jackal white tea i'm just
drinking some what that white tea right
now
drinking some of that and i'm drinking a
discipline go so i'm kind of getting
after it all vitamin chop wawa
and origin main.com also got some we we
talked about jujitsu a little bit today
fortunately let's say it was not
required to be put into use
in guadalcanal no right luckily we still
had we had our bayonet we were able to
just stab
people in the neck and didn't have to
choke them but had it been required we
were happy that people
were trained in jiu jitsu yes sir and
we even if we don't have to use it even
if you don't have to use it
ever in your life in a real situation
believe me you're going to want to have
it so train some jiu-jitsu
and when you train jiu-jitsu you're
going to want a ghee to train in
you're gonna want a rash guard to train
in and you're gonna want those things to
be made
in america and you're also gonna want
them
like you're gonna want the best possible
ones that you could get because you're
kind of making a commitment in your life
to jiu jitsu
you're going to look at yourself in the
mirror and say you know what we're going
to do this
we're going to gain a skill that will
help me in all aspects of my life
do you ever or you know how like you
look at yourself and you kind of have
like a little bit of an
identity varying levels of identity
whatever
do you part of that identity are you
like a jiu jitsu person
for me yeah uh i would say yes
yeah but see how you just said i would
say yes some
because it's a spectrum for sure and not
one one is not better than the other by
the way well the reason i said that is
because
and we've talked about this on the
podcast if it wasn't here's why i
actually it's just a yes because if it
wasn't for jiu jitsu
i wouldn't have be where i am because i
wouldn't have been able to figure out a
bunch of stuff
right like did you see for me the
physical part
the knowing how to submit people or
whatever
that is as far as what i got from jiu
jitsu
this is going to sound crazy that part
the actual being able to fight and beat
people up
of all the beneficial things i got from
jiu jitsu that part
is 20 the 80
benefit that i got from jiu jitsu was an
understanding of the world
now it ties into combat it ties into
leadership and that those things also
participated in
in providing me with that 80 percent
yeah but
the jiu jitsu was the factor that
allowed me to see it
yeah so yeah that makes sense i think i
would agree
with that so yes i'm a jiu jitsu person
yeah so
yeah i feel like if i if i look my
identity i'm not
not a jiu jitsu person but i'm not like
i'm a jiu jitsu you know like if i if
you meet someone
someone's not gonna be like oh yeah
that's a jiu jitsu guy that's not the
first thing they're gonna you're not
known
as a jiu jitsu guy yeah but people know
you do
everybody knows you do jujitsu even
though they also
they also know you do other things other
things yeah that are significant i think
that's why you when i look at you i
don't see okay jiu jitsu guy even though
you're straight up jiu jitsu yeah no
one's gonna say like i yeah he's not
nodded
but then because you have all these
other things that you have like
straight up like for lack of a better
term significant prowess
like in you know i don't know about all
that it's just i don't have significant
prowess in jiu jitsu even i'm still
working on that one what is prowess
really
like doing good at yeah yeah there you
go okay were you worried well i think
that yeah did i
totally miss you anyway i think that
might be the first time i've ever said
that out loud
the word process nonetheless nonetheless
that discipline go kicking in getting
the brain cells working
whether you want to be a jiu-jitsu
person or just
have jiu-jitsu be part of your life you
should definitely make it part of your
life
you're going to need a geek you're going
to need rash guards go to origin
maine.com
and unfortunately for all of us we can't
just walk around in our geese
unfortunately unfortunately so you got
to get other clothing
you can also get that other clothing at
originmaine.com
jeans american-made boots american-made
jeans with
american denim rivets that are from
america
oh guess what everything i'm talking
about without compromise
made in america you go to the brass
buttons
even the brass the brass what buttons
the brass buttons
those are significant sure look at them
they're like yeah they're legit kind of
legit i mentioned the rivets i didn't
mention the
the brass buttons yes sir
origenmaine.com
you're good yes sir also speaking of
other clothing
in jacqueline's store it's called jocko
story that's where you can get t-shirts
hoodies hats
all discipline equals freedom good all
this stuff to represent
while you're on the path
heartburn jam yeah you got that coveted
cough homie
zebra i know you're gonna say i know
you're gonna say that
anyway um also on the t-sh uh
also on jacob's store i was i wait i
know we're we're over covered now but
when
when when i had covered and then you had
kovit
i was a little bit happy because i was
like cool we can still record podcasts
we can't have any guests but at least we
can still go in there and record no
factor
yeah yeah this is true a little bit
happy no no offense
like you know covid plus covet doesn't
equal more
it cancels itself out right yeah kind of
thing all right well i'm clear we're all
clear
nonetheless chocolate store also on
jackal store
we have a t-shirt club working title
t-shirt club get a t-shirt every month
different varying levels
of layers on these t-shirts they're
inside they're
they're easter eggs in the shirts in the
not literal easter eggs but
easter eggs the expression easter eggs
stuff that like if you listen you kind
of know you know
anyway interesting shirts you get one
every month cool club check it out if
you want choco store
dot com also subscribe to the podcast if
you haven't already i think it's
important
varying levels of importance at
chocolate store can't you also just get
rash guards and just like a t-shirt
like this t-shirt that i'm wearing
hardcore condos yes you can
fully i mean you don't have to like go
on there and join the club no
no not at all that's an optional club
right there that we
made it's a good club i mean people
seem to like it maybe if anyone look
let's face it echo tried to come up with
like hey we'll just call it
the t-shirt club okay that's good
if anyone can come up with something
better than that which i'm sure most
people can
please let echo know that you have a
better name
you know even if it was called like the
pickle head club or whatever people
would be like a little bit more into it
yeah well
i don't know what the pickling club but
yeah i i do agree i see what you're
saying and i i
i can't disagree on that one okay all
right cool
we'll bring the people together also
yeah so subscribe if you haven't already
and leave a review if you're in the mood
and go ahead be creative with a review
if you want it's good these are all
all good things also got some other
podcasts
yep we got some other podcast jocko
unraveling podcast we got the grounded
podcast we got the warrior
kid podcast and also if you wanna if you
wanna
join and support
kind of at the next level you can go to
jacounderground.com
where we have a sovereign
a sovereign virtual land that we
rule and that cannot be taken away from
us no matter what happens
so if you want to support that we've got
some extra things going on there we got
some
we got some alternative podcasts that
we're doing we got a little q a
if you're in there you can go to
jockowunderground.com
and join that so we can connect
check it out and you can also check out
youtube videos that echo charles makes
and you can give him some feedback on
in the comment sections well i saw a
comment the other day that said
does jocko read these comments here's
your answer yes i read the comments the
reason i read the comments is so i can
attempt to give echo charles feedback
about the level of
explosions fires smoke tanks
eagles aircraft that he puts in the
videos yes
yeah explosions are kind of like banana
cream pie
you're not gonna eat banana cream pie
for breakfast lunch and dinner
you just have one piece of banana cream
pie
after dinner maybe see
yeah see i see you understand i see the
look on your face ready you understand
i'm doing i'm avoiding carrying on to
this
topic hey look i am subscribed to
subscribe to
uh the youtube channel called
jocklepodcast
boom there you go yep good also
psychological warfare
um look into that one if you're having
moments of weakness look into this
psychological warfare
is an album with tracks jock each track
is jocko telling you
explaining to you the the methodology
the tactic to get past that moment of
weakness easy with these 100 percent
accurate and uh effective
100 that's what psychological warfare is
can you get that wherever you get
mp3s you can get some visual reminders
of the path by going to flip side
flipsidecanvas.com dakota myers company
awesome company
makes really cool stuff to hang on your
walls
got a bunch of books bunch of books
leadership strategy and tactics
field manual i talked about it today
about face
david hackworth which i wrote a forward
to the code the evaluation the protocols
the discipline equals freedom field
manual
brand new version out way the warrior
kid
four field manual get it
we have the warrior kid one two and
three that's the whole series mikey and
the dragons extreme ownership
and the dichotomy of leadership also
have echelon front leadership
consultancy
where we solve problems through
leadership go to echelonfront.com
for details on that we have ef online
where we do leadership consulting
live online we have
leadership courses so if you want to get
deeper into the principles that we talk
about here
you can go into that online training
program and improve your leadership
skills
go to efonline.com i'm on there all the
time so as the rest of the echelon front
team
we have the muster coming up in phoenix
march 3 and
4 orlando may 25th and 26th las vegas
october 28th and 29th those are our 2021
dates
go to extremeownership.com if you want
to go to that ef overwatch if you need
executive leadership inside your company
go to ef
overwatch and if you want to help
service members active and retired you
want to help their families you want to
help gold star families then check out
mark lee's mom mama lee she's got a
charity organization and if you want to
donate or you want to get involved
then go to america's mighty warriors dot
org
and if you didn't get enough of my
belligerent
beliefs or you need more
of echo's speculative speculations
then you can find us on the interwebs on
twitter
on instagram which just echo i'm talking
about what you call
the gram yes and on facebook echo is at
aqua charles i am at jocko willink
i'm also on parlor now by the way okay
new platform and i am at
jacqueline and
thanks to all the branches of service
the army
the navy the air force the marines the
coast guard
thank you for fighting battles out there
so that we don't have to and thanks to
police and law enforcement
and firefighters and paramedics and emts
and dispatchers and correctional
officers and border patrol and secret
service and all first responders
thank you for providing us protection
here at home and to
everyone else out there look we heard
these lessons before
remember them you know them
be disciplined take initiative train
your people
train your people from your front line
troops to your senior leaders
you want them to take initiative and
practice
so you get better make sure the team
knows the objective
you know these things remember these
things
remember these lessons and also remember
where these lessons came from
and remember the men who sacrificed
everything for us
and until next time this is echo and
jocko
out